[Music]
so there's a family that's suing apple
over airpods
because their son
had him in his ear got an amber alert
and it burst his eardrum oh jesus that's
why you gotta turn those off like too
loud it's too loud so the thing with uh
air pods is they don't adjust the volume
for alerts like uh amber alerts no they
should fix that yeah they should fix do
an apple and it has been a long running
thing where they've received complaints
that hey the sound level does not adjust
right because amber alerts are designed
to not adjust because you're supposed to
hear it right but not that loud damn
yeah that's like when you're at the
[ __ ] airport you just chill it and
you know the [ __ ] speaker never is
adjusted to the volume that you're
watching tv and [ __ ] and then be like
watching this jason statham movie so
loud that he's muffled it's [ __ ] loud
irrelevant information we're flying in
this is your captain gilbert gottfried
he's like why what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] why is it so loud you know
it goes if you've been traveling far
like i would you like buy something you
could go on the air boys
i'm like why are you giving [ __ ]
advertisements right now
are you trying to watch a quiet place
yeah jeez
that's uh so they're gonna sue over
there just did dude i feel like they got
a case i think so too especially because
it's been a while that people were
complaining and they they didn't fix it
right because i get maybe that's a
little hard thing to fix because amber
alerts are supposed to be i feel like
dude they can [ __ ] program this thing
to recognize my face you can figure out
a way to turn the volume down yeah dude
i think they should program it they
should program the amber alert to only
go to people who are who could stand a
chance to catch the guy yeah
like this [ __ ] kid's not gonna get up
off his couch and go look for a dude
amber alerts i just feel really guilty
i'm like what the [ __ ] what am i gonna
do no i run to my window
we got zach
it's gonna drive through here any chevy
astros no
i do get them like if i get them i'm
driving i go
oh no i don't see that
it's just like white white
white pickup truck you're just like oh
[ __ ] wait this is the white pickup truck
you call them call the place you're like
i hate to
i hate to be the bearer bed
but i'm driving one
sir please go away
jeez how loud does that need to be to
pop into it
it is so loud it's loud even without
airpods
yeah
even that one uh accidental notification
from the other day that said glendale
glendale
glendale people in the chevy chase
canyon to evacuate that was loud what
was that was that a drill they [ __ ] up
yeah it was a programming error
it's kind of like the missile in hawaii
remember
tattooed
the [ __ ] missile
that started under attack or something
yeah
you're like incoming missile alert
do that that story kept on getting worse
because like they were showing like the
picture of the command center where that
thing went out on and someone had wrote
like the password on a [ __ ] post-it
note
on the on
the computer screen if you were like hey
i don't know if you'd be showing that
and then at that moment everybody
realized how an alert like that could
have gone out because the guy running
astrid is one two three idiots
54.
yeah so they they will there's also a
bunch of cases where some people have
fallen asleep with airpods and then woke
up to being deaf in one ear what though
because of the uh amber alert yeah and
and just different anything alert i
would say sue them for all the money why
don't they have it like at a decibel
that won't destroy your ear ear drums
because uh because the alerts are
designed to override your decibel
setting like
doesn't matter like they're all just
supposed to go out in a highest it's
supposed to max out whoa
that's dangerous so imagine if you're
like a cholo with a banging sound system
and your bluetooth connection
all the windows blow out monte carlo
parts everywhere
funny carlos dude oh no
you're amp setting that's crazy it's
unforgivable they gotta fix that [ __ ]
dude that's so ridiculous it sounds like
something that you just put like two
engineers that you could probably yeah
it sounds like an easy cycle at least
yeah it seems
what about the eardrum technology is
that kid ever going to be able to hear
again from his right ear that's true
it's done yeah that's why they're suing
because they said the the quality of his
life from now on is he just gonna be
totally different i think you could
definitely make an argument how much do
you think he's gonna get
i don't know it depends if he was on
track to be a [ __ ] jazz musician oh
probably just like saying like oh he was
supposed to do this quick uh pick up the
guitar yeah quick does this every day
airpods i think is one of apple's
highest grossing products oh wow i got a
pair yeah they're cool they're great i
like them dollars they're awesome you
guys because you keep losing them so you
have to buy more
yeah they're too losable huh yeah no but
they got that feature that tells me like
annoyingly like when i've left them
somewhere really my airpods or like
their pods that i have will tell me if
it's like if i like leave them at home
or whatever and then it'll be like here
it was last seen here so it's a little
spooky also
that's a good thing to mention when you
when you can't find them you can play
this super loud sound so you can locate
where they are you guys got to show me
this [ __ ] that sound is crazy loud so if
someone steals your air pods and they
have it in their ear you can bust their
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's a good feature is
it a new airbag feature can i just turn
on self-destruct mode
get rid of amber alerts turn on
self-destruct gotta do this because
maybe i'll just be like hey listen to
this and then you put it on you go [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
yeah
as a truce i would like you this new
josh groban
no no no no
now that we're friends i just want you
to hear this real quick
airpods because i chronically lose
things
and i just never bought them so i have
no idea what that experience is like the
big ones yeah usually it's like the big
bows
what about when you work out
i usually wear the even bigger bows
get more weight yeah yeah is that why
you're wearing your neck out at the same
time get the neck pump going gotta max
out your i can't wear those i can't wear
it i just do air pods too i used to do
the [ __ ] string thing because i never
lose them but then like it just gets
caught when i'm running and [ __ ] and i'm
like ah [ __ ] on the door handle and you
just [ __ ] wait what are you doing
you're doing what i hate is when you
have a cord one and like let's say you
go jogging and then all it takes is like
your finger catching one and just whips
out of your [ __ ] ears yeah wireless
is definitely the way to go
the airpods are like is like the best
apple invention in the past like five
years nothing else has been better
outside the amber alerts
honestly amber alerts i don't think they
even work i'm gonna be broke this might
be a hot take i don't think anyone
alright isn't it proven that they're
like the success rates like disneyland i
bet it's it's kind of meant more as a
social comforting thing than it is like
an actual effectiveness
i thought it actually caught people dude
you know
is it kind of like security theater and
tsa or tsa oh yeah it doesn't catch [ __ ]
yeah don't catch it i thought the milk
carton worked probably better yeah i
think so i think so too milk card
techniques you don't even drink milk
nope
nope almond milk almond milk on the
olive oil you know what's funny is if
you did compare the numbers of milk
carton and then amber alert mel carbon
probably has a higher rate because it's
been around longer long time yeah yeah
but a lot of people don't drink milk
anymore so
now we got to do it on soy milk hemp
milk almond milk oh coconut milk oatmeal
so only the vegan criminals are
you gotta put it on the milk that
matches your skin
color so all the caucasian people on the
white milk and then the asians on the
soy milk so we own the banana milk
who's going to get strawberry milk then
native americans i don't know
sunburn irish people
that's cool do you think a vegan family
whose vegan kid went missing would be
offended that their kid was put on a
real milk carton probably
oh that's true they'd be pretty funny we
have such a weird woke society
like these are actually tangibly
like they're going to be questions
that's not a crazy thing i asked right
now
that's a jk news can you please remove
my vegan son from that nutsense i am not
going to support the dairy agriculture
yeah dude i think they could actually be
pissed about pissed over nothing
sounds like you don't like vegans
something like you got beef with vegans
but you're not full vegan that's like
that's like the joke right you know if
two vegans get in a fight is it beef
no that's impossible
[Music]
you